hi everyone i'm jonathan trance and I
got another tactical challenge for you
so when you see the position on the
screen go ahead pause your video and see
if you can solve it alright so here's
this week's puzzle in this position it's
black to move so go ahead and pause your
video see if you can solve it I'll give
you about five to ten seconds but if you
need more time go ahead and pause your
video okay so in this position we notice
that uh okay both sides have bishops but
black has this really powerful beep on
and he's gonna hope to advance it and
make a queen so the first thing you
might think of in this position is just
pushing the pawn and you'll need to
understand what White's defensive
resources is here to understand how
white wouldn't stop the pawn for example
the white King is out of the box so if
he just tries to chase down the pawn
he's not gonna make it in time and black
is gonna queen so going back so where
black just played the move b4 instead I
hope you can you can see the resource
that white has in this position efore
which allows the white bishop access
back to c1 so if you keep pushing bishop
c1 and the pawn is stopped so you're
gonna have a difficult time winning this
so if we go back and we look at this one
more time if you haven't found it go
ahead and again pause your video but if
not here comes the solution the way to
block the e pawn in this position is
with a very pretty and attractive move
Bishop to e4 so you're you're blocking
the pawn to make sure that you can't
play e4 and bring the bishop back so
there's a couple different things that
he can try we'll come back to F takes e4
in just a second but to go over just a
couple other scenarios for example again
if we tried to run the King in well
you're just not gonna be in time black
is faster and white is unable to stop
him from cleaning so let's try another
tricky defense in this position Bishop
to g7 the idea is to play d5 so you're
able to go back and
at the pond in time so go ahead and
again take a couple seconds you can
pause if you need to see if you can
figure out what black needs to play in
this position okay so perhaps the best
move in this position is the simple King
to f7 and if the bishop drops back again
trying to play d5 King g8 and the bishop
is trapped so that wouldn't work for
white so okay let's let's look at the
the main move here F takes e4 and now
the pawn is just too fast so b4 and if
d5 this is another trick we have to make
sure we're paying attention to what
White's trying to do here White's trying
to play Bishop to g7 so again how would
we stop it you can pause and take a look
for yourself the same is in the other
example King to f7 simply prevents the
Bishop from entering the game play might
continue he v b3 Edie Edie and the pawn
is unstoppable
so black wins thank you for watching
another tactical challenge I hope you
guys all enjoyed it hopefully some of
you were able to solve it so a big
congrats to those that were able to get
it right please hit like share subscribe
and we'll see you next week for another
tactical challenge